let's bring in South Carolina Senator
Lindsey Graham Center always great to
see you can I get your take on what the
speaker wants to do do we need a fourth
rescue package well we need to make sure
that phase three actually works we don't
have any checks out yet the unemployment
part of phase three I'm very worried
about every state has an unemployment
Commission to issue unemployment checks
there were three million of people
applied for an employment last week I
think they'll probably be more this week
I'm very concerned that it may take six
to eight weeks to get an unemployment
check and down the road you're paying
people more than they actually make we
got to fix both of those things so I
think the train wreck in this bill is
going to be the unemployment insurance
benefit because it's ministered by state
systems that are stuck in the 70s so I
want to get phase three right before we
go to phase four senator there was talk
of people getting a second check down
the road if there is a phase four it
would that be a part of it do you think
there'll be another check that that
individuals will get it might be but
these checks go to people with jobs I
want to focus on the people or out of
work you know I got a nice working in
South Carolina makes about forty
thousand dollars a year you know quite
frankly she's okay and but somebody laid
off needs to bunny so these direct
payments go to people with income I want
to focus on people without income the
unemployment insurance system in this
country is broken I'm going to spend a
lot of time trying to fix it six to
eight weeks to get a check is what I'm
hearing that's unacceptable and in
unemployment under this bill you're
actually increasing people's wages which
will deter growing the economy we got to
fix both of those things
absolutely but senator you've seen you
know you've been in Washington for a
long time you know how when a big bill
like phase four comes along suddenly
it's like hey what's in it for me and
you know for Nancy Pelosi to talk about
she would like to see infrastructure
frontline workers aid to Washington DC
is that appropriate given what you've
just described
well what I want to do is address the
problem of why what have we learned in
the last 48 hours that the disease is
worse than the cure I don't hear anybody
else compare this to the flu
anymore president Trump has decided to
extend social distancing through the end
of April why because if we do nothing
2.2 billion people are going to die the
coronavirus that's 40 years of flu
deaths in one year so this is a terrible
disease the cure has to be tough so the
idea of creating phase four before you
understand it phase three works doesn't
make any sense to me I'm hoping that
what we're doing now in April and May
will slow the disease down come summer
the the heat will stop it spread and by
the fall we'll be ready to go at it with
therapies and vaccines but before I want
to talk about phase four I want to make
sure if phase three works and if anybody
puts a damn dime in phase four unrelated
to the virus they're going to be very
famous because we're people people are
dying in this country it's not now time
to do the neat green new deal there's
any green New Deal stuff in phase four
if there is a phase four there'd be one
hell of a fight
because 2.2 million Americans lives are
at risk here
well absolutely but the gun was to
everybody's head
senator this started in China and China
has not owned up to this what do you
want to do about this how much control
do we have of stopping the next virus
from coming through well I'm all right a
letter to the World Health Organization
into the Chinese vest ambassador asking
asking them to close the Chinese wet
markets these are open air markets where
this they sell monkey they sell bat we
think we this whole thing started from a
transmission from a bat to a human about
the last three or four pandemics have
come from the Chinese wet markets I
don't think this came from a Chinese
military lab but these wet markets are
gross they're just absolutely disgusting
selling exotic animals that transmit
viruses from animals to human beings
those things need to shut down
do you think that's gonna do it I mean
there's yeah there there's been
controversy with World Health
Organization through all of this do you
think China is really going to listen
well I think we should I'm gonna write a
letter to the Chinese ambassador saying
if you don't shut those wet markets down
our trading relationship is going to
change the source of this virus is the
Chinese wet markets but when you look
have doctors who come on and ask them
how many diseases have come from China
through these wet markets where you
intermingle all kind of exotic animals
is just really a gross display of how
you prepare food that needs to stop what
can China do to help the world shut
those markets down and speaking of shut
down
senator what about your office is it the
social distancing thing is everybody
working from home or what's going on we
have most people working from home but
we have we have all the offices manned
we're trying to tell up communicate the
best we can but we have people at the
offices and our governor's done a good
job here we're trying to trying to abide
by the guidelines I hope by April the
30th will have turned the corner here
but the president's decision to extend
social distancing through April 30th was
based on sound science here's what the
president realized this is not the flu
2.2 million people could die in a single
year that is forty-year flu deaths so
the cure in this case has to be
draconian because the disease is so
deadly testing has changed that's good
news we have millions of tests available
not thousands we do it in minutes not
days so we're turning the corner in
testing and the sooner we'll get more
tests the more normal America will
become yeah I cannot wait for that day
Senator Lindsey Graham thanks for
leading the charge on this appreciate
you joining us this morning thanks